that one's vanellope baby they love you
yeah I'm so distracted I cut look at
this little guy stuff like this you know
this is what I set out to do was just
play with puppies all the time I think
the great thing about acting is that you
can step into somebody else's shoes
without suffering the consequences I was
a kind of person who was like I was a
swimmer I also really loved art and I
train like classically as a vocalist for
10 years
right watch the Gaga concert and I
started writing music and then I at the
end of that year iota since ajoomma
school and I didn't get in and so I
decided to do it a plumber's music
theater and then from that I figured I
liked the acting thing anyway so now I'm
here what's your drag name it's hard I
would I'd get on board with that
drag name what breed of dog are you I
have a drag name what's your temperature
I don't know if I can swear I'm lesbian
sir oh yeah yeah what did you know
that's I hope that this movie furthers a
conversation of representation and
inclusiveness and tolerance
see your story represented on a screen
is a really powerful thing I think
representation is is crucial it's so
important to see people who look like
you and act like you and to see stories
that you can relate to because it's what
it's what makes you feel not crazy or
not alone this is a story that's kind of
it's overdue but I hope that it
normalizes those feelings because I
think it's so underrepresented in the
media and you know if you don't see
those stories you don't understand them
and then it makes it weird to be that
and I just I think it takes so much
courage to come out and hopefully this
film can no more shoot it talking for it
to ease it all makes just like a scene
in the movie if you watch it there's
something exactly this happens
exceptive dogs maybe not quite as cute I
[Music]
feel like now more than ever is a time
where you can find a community or
whether it's online or can find people
with like-minded views don't be afraid
to be vulnerable I can't give personal
advice because like everyone's story is
different and I've never had to go
through coming out or anything like that
knowing that like you're not alone and
your friends if they're real friends
will accept you and love you and oh wait
no there's guys are no friends we have
to separate you too
[Music]
I never fit in like I was an athlete but
I was also a musical when I was also a
super nerd but also like none of them
ever felt right you're conflicting ideas
of like you're trying so hard to be
authentically you but at the same time
you're like Who am I and trying to like
figure that out what would you like in
high school Nick I feel like I was kind
of a misfit I didn't really belong to
any one group I've never had to do
anything with puppies before this is
harder than I thought it was going to be
him
[Music]
don't try and fit in as hard don't be
afraid to be vulnerable and trust your
instincts a little bit more high schools
a time when you know you're trying
really hard to express yourself but you
don't always have the tools emotional
tools to do that just pet puppies my
advice would be keep doing what you're
doing because I feel like I wouldn't
change anything I read it did you read
it
mhm yeah yeah I read Oscar I loved it I
was such a fangirl of the book I reached
out to Becky on Instagram and just like
BAM here this is your guy
adapting a novel for a film is tricky
because the backstory have to include
and like an hour and a half baby don't
leave me you want a little backstory the
novel is really great in the book they
go much more into like Leah and her
insecurities and I think that's a really
large part of what's going on with her
is like not only the whole emotional
journey but also how she feels about
herself I got to read the book and it
just had a lot of depths these
characters that maybe this is because of
her background she used to be a school
counselor but she's really good at
making these characters
three-dimensional and showing their
their journey
I think we did justice to it I hope that
that if you liked the book you'll like
the movie and if you've never read the
book I highly recommend checking it out
we went to Savannah which was cool
except for the goats turd did not enjoy
that oh yeah Savannah was actually the
best part of that yeah you also taught
me how to drive I knew how to drive you
drove on the other side of the road yeah
you've driven a car before yeah no no no
I join a car you didn't let's specify
you didn't teach me how to drive but oh
babe come on it's not fun
what's my finger it's not like
delectable or something what sorry
puppies definitely not ready to direct a
movie but if I was to direct a film I
like movies that are hard to pin down
I like Donnie Darko like something along
those lines
you're my movie I mean Jake Gyllenhaal
and Donnie when I watched it I was like
that's Nick yeah yeah actually don't
know if that's a compliment thank you
Tom okay I don't feel ready to direct
something I'd like to direct but I think
if I did it I would want to be ready to
do it I really like the idea of
capturing parts of yourself that you
keep to yourself and you don't show to
people I think that's really cool
actually I had this idea to tell like
when you fall in love with someone but
from like a girl's perspective for
another girl like I had a friend who
told me about that and she just had a
really beautiful story oh god I can't
even think I can barely like think about
what I'm doing tomorrow I can't think
five to ten years
yeah I like to do more acting and I said
quietly yeah I tell you I'd also like to
do some music because I think I came
from a music background I like the last
two years to me and I did like there's
reasons and I did this and they're just
coming out now but like I think music is
still at my core so I don't know maybe
put some music out because my friends
desperately want me to do that because
I've known me since I started writing so
we'll see we'll see
thank you so much she's not leaving me
[Music]